what do you think can achieve peace in
the war in Ukraine looking at another
part of the world if you if you consider
the fight for peace in this part of the
world
how can you apply that to that other
part of the world between Russia and
Ukraine now
I think it's one of the um
the Savage horrors of history and one of
the great tragedies that is occurring
um
and let me say in advance that uh that
if I have any opportunity to
use my uh contacts to help bring about
an end to this tragedy I'll do so uh
I've had I know both leaders
but I don't just jump in and and assume
you know if there's be a desire at a
certain point
because the conditions have
created the possibility of
helping stop this uh this Carnage then
I'll do it and that's why I choose my
words carefully because I think that may
be the best uh uh the best thing that I
could do
um look I I think what you see
um in Ukraine is what happens if you
have
um territorial designs on a territory by
a country that has nuclear weapons
and that to me you see the change in the
equation now
I think that people are loath to use
nuclear weapons and I'm not sure that I
would think that the the Russian side
would use them
with happy abandon I don't think that's
the question but you see how the whole
configuration changes uh when that
happens so you have to be very careful
on how you resolve this conflict so it
doesn't
uh
well it doesn't go off the rails so to
speak that's by the way the the
corollary is here we don't want Iran
which is an aggressive force with an un
just aggressive ideology of dominating
first the Muslim world and then
eliminating Israel and then becoming a
you know a global force uh having
nuclear weapons it's totally different
when they don't have it than when they
do have it and that's why one of my main
goals has been to prevent Iran from
having the means to uh the means of mass
destruction which will be used atomic
bombs which they openly say will be used
against us and you can understand that
how to bring about an end to Ukraine
I have my ideas I don't think I don't
think it's worthwhile uh
discussing them now because they might
they might be required later on do you
believe in the power of conversation
since you have contacts with Vladimir
zielinski and Vladimir Putin just
leaders sitting in a room
And discussing how the end of War can be
brought about
I think it's a combination of that but I
think it's the question of interest and
uh and whether you have to get both
sides
to a point where they
think that that conversation would lead
to something useful I don't think
they're there right now what part of of
this is just basic human ego
stubbornness all of this between leaders
which is why I bring up the power of
conversation of sitting in a room
realizing we're human beings and then
there's a history that connects Ukraine
and Russia yeah I don't think they're in
a position to enter a room right now
realistically I mean you can posit that
it would be good if that could happen
but entering the room is sometimes more
complicated than what happens in the
room and there's a lot of you know
pre-negotiation on the negotiation then
you negotiate endlessly on the
negotiation they're not even there